il habite l'un des chs ld les plus
touchées de la province par la coved 19
à travers le nuage noir
enfin un peu de soleil l'arrivée de
tablettes électroniques a permis à
plusieurs familles de renouer
malgré la distance on a vécu du stress
de l'inquiétude
on a brouillé mais quand on l'a vu quand
il nous a sourit ça a été merveilleux on
dirait que gros pour qui s'est allégé
sur nos épaules lesieu sa fournissent et
stable est la fondation de la santé et
des services sociaux de l'énergie a
doublé le nombre d'ipod disponibles en
plus d'en offrir aux usagers des soins
palliatifs et des soins intensifs de
l'hôpital de shawinigan sud
on sent vraiment que dans les familles
ça use un bel écho qu'en ce moment c'est
ce qu'on essaie de faire nous générer un
peu d'humanité sommet du bonheur
on est là pour ses pions ce qu'en fait
on a toujours été là pour ça mais
l'actuel mandat cette période là on se
colle vraiment sur cette partie de notre
mission denise l'habillant ainsi pu
échanger à plusieurs reprises avec son
père meurt connu ça c'est ma fille donne
et puis j'ai vu la verte qui est fait
qu'ils étaient vraiment lui qui était en
forme malgré son coville qui donc n'ont
jamais eu des préposés aux bénéficiaires
accompagne chaque jour les résidents et
les aident à établir la communication
la docteur nathalie bruit a
immédiatement constaté une amélioration
du moral des résidents même pour ceux
qui reçoivent les soins palliatifs
même si parfois sont en fin de vie de
revoir leur famille les familles qui
peuvent leur parler
qui leur dira tout ce qu'ils ont à dire
avant qu'il dessert
c'est très touchant de vivre ça avec eux
ils prennent le temps de le faire ce ban
apprécié un gros merci à ces gens à
l'eau et si jonathan roberge radio
canada shawinigan